if if you are getting paid uh for  renting out your time and that even  includes lawyers and includes uh doctors  you can make some money uh you're just  not gonna make the kind of money that uh  gives you your financial freedom you're  not gonna have passive income where  business is earning for you while you  sleep and while you are on vacation so  when you own equity in a company that  basically means you own the upside when  you own debt you own guaranteed revenue  streams and you own the downside you  want to own equity if you don't own  equity in a business  then i think your your odds of making  money are very slim so you have to kind  of walk up to the point where you can  own equity in the business and you can  own equity as a small shareholder where  you bought stock but you can also own it  as an owner where you started the  company  so ownership is really important